so this arrived in the post some while
ago and you can see from its the Nobel
Committee for physics and chemistry the
Royal Swedish Academy of Science and on
the bottom you see it says Oh 101 for
four out of a thousand so I think I was
number 144 on their list of a thousand
people they sent it out to secrecy
requirements you can read that you
should treat your invitation and
nominations highly confidential so I'm
not going to tell you who I voted for
it's one of those very closely guarded
secrets so nobody knows ahead of time
lots of people try to predict it they
almost always get it completely wrong
and this year is no exception all the
predictions were not the people who
ended up winning the prize I believe
there is a panel that decides it and
they actually send out letters so I've
actually got a letter from the Nobel
Foundation a year or so back which you
know caused some excitement because you
don't get letters from the Nobel
foundation every day but all they would
they weren't saying congratulations
you've won the prize they just said you
know do you have anyone you think who we
should be considering so they do go out
and consult and find out what you know
what the views are is that the
scientific community
I've been asked for some suggestions and
for some views in the past and I think
what I've written down it has to remain
secret for 50 years so I don't think I'm
going to tell you much about that either
they're saying who would you think in
your professional experience is somebody
who is deserving of a Nobel Prize for
whatever reason and then give your
reasons inside the most influential
papers that lead you to do this so that
they have a accurate record of your
opinion which is meant to be independent
of everybody else and then you're giving
the evidence so that you can make a case
and if enough people write it in support
of somebody from all over the world then
that gets near the top of the list and
then they make a decision so today was
the announcement of the Nobel Prize for
Physics so over a series of a few days
the prizes for all the different areas
that they actually give out Nobel prizes
in or announced so it's the physicists
turn today so much excitement in the
physics community to figure out who's
won who's now a million dollars better
off so it was actually split it quite
often is a split award and it was split
two ways this time while it split
between three people but for two
different things so half of it went to a
guy called your Charles cow for the
invention of fiber optics fibrotic
technology and the other half went to
two physicists from the Bel Air
in the United States William Boyle and
George Smith for the invention of the
CCD the charge-coupled device it's a I
mean it's it's strange because actually
in some sense I guess the pure
physicists are a little frustrated
because in some sense what's been given
the prize here is a piece of technology
piece of engineering so it's it's an
interesting one but it's perhaps a
little bit unexpected in that I think
quite a few people felt that the the
prize might go for a rather more
fundamental discovery there are people
who've done fantastic work in
theoretical physics or in experimental
work but once in a while it's a good to
remind the public that what we do is
there's a great practical use to the
rest of the world the stuff that excites
me is not so much the engineering side
of physics it's really answering the big
deep fundamental questions and of course
we need the technology to do that but
it's you know getting up at the heart of
matter what is that the structure matter
what is the structure the universe
fundamental quantum mechanical problems
fundamental of basic physics fundamental
physics problems I guess that's what
excites me it doesn't excite you know
that might excite other physicists
rather less than it excites me but that
I guess that's perhaps my take on it
I mean fiber optics obviously has kind
of revolutionized a lot of things in
terms of broadband internet and cable
television and so on so I've been a huge
impact on the world the other the CCD
the charge-coupled device has also
actually had a huge impact in the world
the reason why you're able to film me at
the moment is because you're using the
camera with the CCD in the back in fact
you know all digital cameras use those
CCD devices and so it's really the
device that allows you to store images
digitally and obviously that has a huge
impact in astronomy as well in the old
days fortunately just before I started
in astronomy back in the 1980s we used
to record images on photographic plates
and so you can make nice pictures with
photographic plates plus a couple of
problems with them personally they're
not very sensitive they're about 1% are
sensitive as a CCD is so actually you
have to observe the same thing for a
hundred times as long with a
photographic plate but the other thing
is that if you take a photographic plate
you end up with a photographic plate and
then there's not a whole lot you can do
with it really I mean you have to you
know you can look at it but that's about
it
whereas with a CCD you end up with the
information in a digital form
and it's a beautiful digital form in the
sense that for every photon of light
that arrives you end up recording one
count so you really are seeing the light
as it arrives and really recording a
completely undistorted image of the
object that you're looking at but in
essence what happens is every time a
photon a particle of light comes in it
liberates one electron within a pixel
within one of the elements of this
device and so really you turning light
into charge and then you just need to
measure the amount of charge you've
recorded and that tells you how much
lights arrived and hence how bright the
thing was that you were looking at so
the world of fiber-optic is is basically
it's a strand of glass and the beauty is
of strands of glass is that you can
actually get light to travel along them
even when the strand isn't straight so
you can use light to transfer
information around very quickly
obviously at the speed of light but the
elegant thing about the fiber optics is
that you don't have to have the light
traveling in straight lines it will
actually follow the curve of the glass
and physically the way that works is
through a process called total internal
reflection well this is a demonstration
of an optical fiber in action our fiber
isn't a slender gas glass thing that
will be used in communications rather
it's a bent perspex rod but the
principles are just the same the light
is going to bounce around inside we're
going to send an audio signal through
this rod now we need a sound source of
course and that's provided by the the
radio here rather old-school thing and
the sound comes out of the radio via
this cable here into this little piece
of circuitry and all that does is it
just turns the signal the sound signal
into a light signal essentially you can
see a little light emitting diode here
and that's producing an amount of light
and the amount of light varies depending
on how big a voltage or how big the
signal is coming out of the radio here
and then the light once we've aligned it
will travel up the optical fiber are
bent perspex rod going all around
obviously isn't straight so it has to
bounce off the sides and there's a
something called total internal
reflection which is that the physics
that drives all optical fibers and if
you've ever dived into a swimming pool
and looked up at the surface if you look
at kind of an oblique angle to the
surface you actually end up seeing a
reflection the light doesn't actually
travel through the surface of the water
it actually gets reflected internally
reflected and the way a fiber-optic work
is as the light travels along every time
it hits the side it basically gets
internally reflected so the light sort
of bounces its way down the fiber-optic
cable
and at the very end here we have the
sidled Goldie looking thing is a
photosensitive diode and when the lights
when we align it to the light will hit
that little diode and it'll generate a
current on the amount of current is
proportional to the amount of light so
that's a signal is recovered back and we
can feed that into a pair of speakers
here and hear the sound hopefully the
original sound so what we'll do is we'll
turn up our volume on the speakers will
align the diode at this end with the end
of the fiber so the light is now going
into the end of the fiber traveling
along but of course once it reaches this
end it isn't yet troubling into our
photo diode and we'll push the diode up
again there and if you listen carefully
it anyone ever tried the cabbage diet
and there we go dinky diet pills that's
local radio coming through optical fiber